we're on the set every day your
superhero that's got a hammer
yeah a a serious hammer and I think to
myself sometimes is that because you use
it all the time is it do you think it's
really a practical weapon it's kind of
ridiculous isn't it it's a little
ridiculous yeah you picture him like
they're like you can have a sword you
can have like giving him 15 right
amazing things and he's like a hammer
the really large hammer head and the
short stumpy shaft thing and then hey
everyone this is Charlie you guys were
requesting a video about Thor's new
weapon we got some new details that make
it seem like they're actually combining
a couple different comic book weapons so
I've already done a couple videos about
how I think they're doing his axe from
the comics just based on the stuff that
we know but now this new information
just adds a little bit of context so
with that in mind there is a new route
of the Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and just leave a comment on
the video this really isn't something I
consider spoilery because it's all based
on stuff that we've seen in the trailer
so far so if you've seen all the
Infinity Ward trailers and you've seen
Thor Ragnarok you have a pretty good
idea where they're taking this so
everybody saw what happened to Mjolnir
during Thor Ragnarok
[Music]
possible darling you have no idea what
it's possible hello smashes it into a
thousand pieces and that's the last we
hear about it it was made of room metal
you don't just find that lying around
everywhere so Blockbuster filmmaking we
can assume that at some point somebody
got those pieces and they're sitting in
a bag somewhere so part of the idea of
ragnarok is that the old stuff dies and
new stuff lives on like thor becomes
King Thor so Mjolnir dies and becomes
the new version of the weapon which is
why it sounds like they're doing a
combination of Stormbreaker in ultimate
Mjolnir from the comics with an extra
added twist with help from guardians of
the galaxy most of you probably know
that Stormbreaker is actually beta ray
bill's weapon in the comics beta ray
bill was a character during Ragnarok but
his scene got deleted so technically
he's part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but you can't really count him
officially because he hasn't been seen
on screen only an easter egg form on the
side of this building during the contest
of Champions it was implied that he was
one of the previous champions before the
Hulk came along does he have any
weaknesses
[Music]
but what happened in the comics is is
beta ray bill got into a fight with Thor
and won the right to wield Mjolnir but
he himself felt like it belonged to Thor
so he gave it back to him in a
recognition for his prowess in battle
defeating Thor is no small feat and
becoming worthy of Mjolnir Odin granted
him a new hammer that he went to the
dwarfs to forge he called it
Stormbreaker it was made of the exact
same Guru metal that Mjolnir was made of
if the small change is that it was gold
instead of silver like Mjolnir and it
had a bit of an axe on the back of it
but obviously it's not a true ax ax just
has this pointed stubby end here the
hammer that we refer to as ultimate
Mjolnir belonged to Thor from the
Ultimate Universe
he died during secret Wars but somehow
the hammer survived the creation of the
new universe so in the comics more
recently there have been two versions of
Mjolnir the regular one that's been
wielded by the female version of Thor
who's Jane Foster in a new version of
Thor that was called the war Thor
because he was so hardcore he was gonna
wield the most hardcore version of
Mjolnir so you look at it here and it's
just next-level hardcore compared to
Mjolnir in Stormbreaker so what it seems
like they're doing an infinity war his
Thor takes the pieces of mule near back
to the Dwarven Forge where it was
created the first time Andrey forges
himself a new version of the hammer that
just extra hardcore and he calls it the
storm breaker but because it's a
reforged version of Mjolnir he probably
winds up using the axe side a lot more
when they're fighting the outriders here
or when he's fighting Thanos in the
Black Order the thing about all the
infinity war trailers is the only time
we've seen Thor so far is when he's with
the guardians we do not see him in any
of these other scenes when they're
fighting Thanos we can probably assume
if he spends most of his time with the
guardians in the guardians are the way
that Iron Man gets to this place where
they fight Thanos then Thor is probably
with them somewhere off of camera just
remember that Thor's not a magician and
he's not a scientist so all the special
properties that the hammer has if
they're gonna try and do that for this
version of the weapon somebody else is
gonna have to do that like either Loki
will have to enchant it or the dwarves
will have to lay some enchantments on it
but we can talk a little bit more about
Thor's powers the next time we spot them
in a trailer here's the really cool part
though look at the handle for the axe
doesn't that look a lot different than
the
I'll handle for Mjolnir it looks more
organic you also see that there's a leaf
on it in this picture here so what this
implies is that uninteresting route who
could care less about what they're doing
here he's playing his video game still
provides the wood to create the handle
for this now a lot of people saw this in
their life does that mean that Groot
dies no that is now what that means
they're not gonna kill teenage Groot
right after they killed him during the
original guardians of the galaxy that's
probably part of his call to action
during the movie like oh I can actually
do something that contributes to the
heroes fight I'm not gonna sit here and
play video games like an while
everybody gets killed by Thanos you know
what's sitting there so in the trawler
shot here where it looks like rocket is
flying Thor to the space Forge to have
the dwarves help him make a new version
of the weapon that explains why Groot is
with them because why would you bring
teenage Groot if he's not gonna help out
and for those that are wondering that is
Vin Diesel doing the voice for him we
haven't heard him speak in any of the
trailers he's about as tall as Peter
Parker who looks really tiny standing
next to Robert Downey jr. in Doctor
Strange Tom Holland isn't really tiny
it's just that Robert Downey jr. is
wearing his Iron Man armor which adds a
lot to his size Benedict Cumberbatch is
a lot taller than both of them just
naturally but let me know in the
comments what do you think about Thor's
new weapon the fact that they're
combining comic book weapons I'm okay
with them calling it storm breaker
because the movies change a lot of
things as long as it's cool in the
moment as long as the scene works I'm
totally fine with it as long as we get
beta ray bill at some point in one of
these marble cosmic movies if they never
do beta ray bill then I'll be a little
salty what'll happen next is is because
Black Panther is dropping pretty much
everywhere tomorrow I'll start doing
post credit scene videos my spoilery
review more infinity war as it applies
to the end of black panther and all the
stuff that we would normally have to
wait about two people had seen the movie
so those videos should start rolling out
in the next day or two just leave all
your requests in the comments below and
all name of the giveaway winner when I
post my next Marvel video but click here
to learn about spider-man's next big
costume upgrade and click here for brand
new flash thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see you
tonight
[Music]